MIKE PODWAL: Hello.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
My name is Mike.
I'm a product
manager on Daydream.
It's awesome to be here.
So just to start things
off, how many of you just
attended the talk on Google VR?
[CHEERING]
Yeah, I thought so--
a lot of people.
That's great.
For those of you who weren't
there, in that talk we just
announced Daydream Labs, our
rapid prototyping effort.
We're excited to tell
you all about it.
So we'll dive right in.
At Google, we spend a
lot of time thinking
about what works well in VR.
Our industry has come a long
way exploring the possibilities,
discovering its
killer use cases,
learning how to design
a great experience.
And part of what makes
VR so exciting right now
is that it's still early days.
There is so much
left to explore.
So last year, we
started Daydream Labs.
Our goal is to
experiment with VR
and share what we
learn with everyone.
We do research and
rapid prototyping
on lots of things like
hardware and usability.
One area we focus on
is app experiments.
We build bit-sized prototypes
that allow us to quickly test
a single hypothesis about VR.
We don't focus on any
particular product or platform.
And we love building on all
kinds of hardware-- HTC Vive,
Oculus, Daydream, and more.
For each experiment,
we try to pick
the right tool for the job.
And we try to move pretty fast.
On average, we build two new
app experiments each week.
And if you're interested in
learning a little bit more
about the process for
our rapid prototyping,
we have another talk today at
4:00 PM that's all about it.
Check it out.
Just a quick overview of how we
work-- for each app experiment,
we pair one engineer
with one designer.
They start the week
building stuff.
By the end of the
week, they'll share it
with a bunch of people,
get their feedback,
and see what we learned.
And then we share those
lessons within Google.
Today, we're so excited
to start sharing
these lessons with everyone.
In this talk, we'll
walk through what we've
learned across
three areas-- first,
interactions, the
amazing things you
can do in VR with a
controller; second, immersion,
your environment in VR and all
the things that contributes
to a sense of presence;
and finally, social,
what it's like to share these
experiences with other people.
So with that, I'll
hand it over to Stefan
to talk to you
about interactions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
STEFAN WELKER: Hi everyone.
It's great to be here.
My name is Stefan Welker.
I'm a software
engineer on Daydream.
Let's talk about interactions.
To set some context, in VR,
the main way people interact
is by using a controller
that is tracked in 3D space.
What's awesome is that these
controllers can look and act
like any tool.
Your controller can
be a laser pointer
that makes it possible to
reach things that are far away.
And that can be across
the room or even
across the whole galaxy.
Controllers can also
become your virtual hands.
But there is no reason
to limit yourself
to these common input types.
Your controller can also turn
into a hammer, a tennis racket,
a fishing rod, or
even a frying pan.
Come on, this is crazy.
AUDIENCE: Woo.
[LAUGHTER]
STEFAN WELKER: Your controller
can become any tool or toy.
In a sense, the visual
representation drives its use.
And since we humans
are naturally
good at using proxy objects like
tools to manipulate the world,
controllers also
feel very natural.
With accurate tracking
in VR, the skills
needed to interact with objects
in the real world or in VR
are already present
in everybody.
So nobody has to learn
how to use a controller.
Let's walk through a
few of the interaction
models that are possible.
One of our first lessons
was that direct manipulation
of objects-- for example,
picking something up
with your hands-- is one of
the most natural and satisfying
input methods.
In this experiment, we let
you play drums, which was fun.
We also gave people the
ability to grab and move
the drums by grabbing
them with a controller.
We learned that
height adjustment
and ergonomic positioning
is really easy in VR.
People quickly built their dream
drum kits and started to play.
There is no feeling like
building your own drum fort
and hiding inside it.
[LAUGHTER]
We also found that
everybody really
likes throwing things in VR.
[LAUGHTER]
Gestural input is a
very powerful concept.
In this prototype,
you scoop up seeds
and you water them
with a watering can.
People already know how to
use a real watering can,
so they expect the same
behavior of these VR objects.
There is no need for
any buttons here.
We then took it
even a step further.
In this experiment, people
weren't holding a controller
at all.
They were holding
a real watering can
where we stuck a Vive
controller inside.
We matched the geometry,
so it is really satisfying
to touch an object in
VR and in the real world
at the same time.
We added some weight, so it's
weighted with a bag of water.
And we expected that
people would set it down
because it would feel heavy.
But it connected for
them the real world
and the virtual worlds together
in a delightful manner.
You can only imagine
what kinds of objects
could be tracked in
VR in the future.
Designing environments
is much more natural
when you are in the
environment yourself.
In this living room
examples, we give the users
superpowers like
lifting heavy objects
or even scaling them with
a simple stretch gesture.
Doing these things on
a traditional 2D user
interface with a mouse
would be pretty hard.
Yet they're very intuitive given
positional controller input.
In this experiment,
we also learned
that giving users
creative freedom
can lead to unexpected outcomes.
In the app, we added
a clone button.
People started to replicate
objects lots of times.
They were very creative.
They built trees
out of speakers.
[LAUGHTER]
But ultimately, we learned that
this creative freedom can also
distract from the
app's core use case.
As a developer,
you should consider
that if you want to
direct the user to perform
certain tasks in your app.
Controllers for VR
have become incredibly
precise and responsive.
But just because this
precision is possible,
we don't require everyone
to be precise all the time.
Fluid interactions can be
supported by allowing throwing
or snapping together of objects.
In VR, imprecise actions can
lead to an ordered result
instead of chaos.
In our photo experiment,
you can throw things
at a wall to create
a wall paper,
toss them around the
room to share them,
or scoop up a whole
mess of photos
just with one fluid motion.
You can create a really
neatly organized folder.
To the user, it feels like the
system is reading their minds.
And it just works.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[TAPPING]
We call this one drum keys.
This is a volumetric keyboard.
The buttons give visual,
sound, and haptic feedback
to the user.
This makes the keyboard feel
responsive and fun to use.
The feedback may
seem very subtle,
but it is very noticeable
when it is missing.
Just for kicks, we
made a game out of it
to see who had the
highest words per minute.
There are so many new
things you can learn and do
with a VR controller.
You should really
try it yourself.
It's really eye-opening to
use computers in this way.
With this, I'm going
to hand over to Manuel
to talk about immersion.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
MANUEL CLEMENT: Hello, my
name is Manuel Clement.
I'm the designer/crazy
prototyper on Daydream.
In VR, there are
many things that
contribute to a
sense of immersion--
your environment, how you
move around, audio, and more.
Let's look at a few things
we've tried and learned
about creating the sense of
immersion and even increase it.
This prototype
demonstrates the importance
of fluid, reactive environments.
In VR, your environment
is everything around you--
in this case, a simple
floor, a wall, and the sky.
People naturally want to
interact with their world,
manipulate it.
They push, they
pull, they reach,
and they even throw stuff.
The more reactive your
environment, the more immersive
it will be.
People will feel connected.
It's so amazing to see
your virtual world respond,
come to life, obey or even
break the laws of physics.
After interacting with
their environment,
the first thing people
want to do is move around.
The challenge is that many
of the techniques that
allow people to move around
in large virtual environments
can also make them lose
context, which breaks immersion.
In this case, you're looking
at a technique commonly called
teleportation.
It works in most cases.
Like, at one point
there's a Google logo.
I want to go here.
Oh, there you go.
When there's a Google
logo and you go there--
because you have a frame of
reference, it works fine.
But if you advancing through
a forest and everything
kind of looks the same,
it's hard to understand
what just happened.
So we tried many things.
We explored things
to enable movement
while preserving
context when moving
around large environments.
We call this one
Slides and Ladders.
Pay attention to
the top left corner.
You can see a video of
myself moving around
in RR, real reality.
Notice how small the room is.
It's about five feet by
12 feet, not very large.
There's slides that
do what you expect.
When you sit down
on them, they go.
There's ladders you just
reach and pull to climb.
There's a virtual
gondola you can ride.
And even you can float on
a cloud across the sky.
When people took
of their headset,
they were stunned to see
how small the room was.
They had forgotten because
the VR environment they
had experienced was massive.
They never lost context.
They traveled through
a huge space there.
We can't wait to
see what you all
will come up with
to do teleportation
and movement in VR.
Here we built a
conveyor belt game
lets you sort through
cubes and eat donuts.
What's important
here is that it shows
how even a flat-looking
environment needs texture
and shadows to feel real.
In real reality, we never
encounter flat colors.
Let's imagine that a large
object fills our field
of view in VR, like a wall.
It needs texture to maintain
your sense of depth and scale.
Look at the conveyor
belt. You'll
see that it's moving, because
it has a simple noisy texture.
What does it mean to you all?
Stay away from flat
colors and materials.
Now we're going to
do a little exercise.
Let's all try to be quiet for
a few min-- a few seconds,
not minutes.
I'm going to count down.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
As you probably
noticed, the real world
is never truly silent.
Now let's all go somewhere else.
[BIRDS CALLING]
[WAVES CRASHING]
I hear birds right there.
And there was water
all around me.
In VR, technologies
like spatial audio
allow you to have audio coming
from specific 3D locations.
Audio is so important.
We have a talk tomorrow
morning 9:00 AM.
Do not miss it.
For those of you who are
used to 2D experiences,
it's worth pointing out that in
VR, the world is your 3D stage.
You can have 2D UI like
the map on this wall,
where it makes sense.
Additionally, the 3D map
in the middle of the room
displays dynamic data
over time, in this case,
US population per state.
Users can walk around.
They can inspect things
and compare data points.
3D makes it easy to understand
sizes and relationships
intuitively.
OK, we're all here today.
That means that our
ancestors at one point,
they were in savanna.
And they were able to tell
the difference between a kitty
cat and a lion.
So bring on 3D UI.
The goal should not always
to be replicating reality.
Reality is great in many cases.
However, as humans,
a few crazy elements,
ingredients can create
these environments really
make you want to stay
immersed in them.
How about floating
apples and bananas?
Let's be serious for a second.
We call this one Fruit Salad.
Time and again, we saw
people more engaged
with playful environments.
They were more delighted to
invest time in the experience
and explore.
Don't be constrained by reality.
When you design
new environments,
consider multiple vantage
points, different scales.
We call this one Dollhouse.
And when people realized
they could become tiny,
they screamed with joy.
The kid inside them had
always wanted to do this.
It's amazing.
This reminds me of
my own daughter.
She loves to make fairy
houses in our backyard.
And her deepest wish
is to experience
these magical worlds,
to become a fairy.
What if you were as big as the
galaxy or as small as an atom?
I mean, you notice VR
is a unique opportunity
to experience the impossible.
And now I'm going
to hand it over
to Robbie who will talk
about social in VR.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBBIE TILTON: Thanks.
Hey everyone.
I'm Robbie Tilton, a designer
and prototyper on the Daydream
team.
We've talked about interactions
and building immersive worlds.
Let's talk about social.
Our industry has already
explored many possibilities
with social and VR.
Social apps really let
you feel like you're
in the same room
as someone else,
regardless of where
you are in the world.
We've done some experiments
too, and we're really
excited to share some
of what we've learned.
Let's start with avatars. .
There are many ways to
represent people in VR.
First, we found
even simple avatars
can be extremely expressive.
This avatar's head only
has a pair of eyes,
and it's still able to
communicate a lot of emotion
just with the way it moves.
When you combine this
with hands and voice,
all things come together
to give a real sense
of shared presence.
You really feel like they're
there in the room with you.
Let's talk about eyes
in a little more detail.
In this video, you
see the avatar blink,
which is programmed to
happen at a random interval.
When the head turns,
the pupils move
in the direction it's headed.
Even without other
facial features
like a mouth or
eyebrows, we were
surprised by how connected we
felt to this other individual.
Eyes amplify face-to-face
communication.
They give people a clear place
to look to and speak toward.
And we called this
one Googly Eyes.
When you're in VR
and your avatar only
has a head and hands, one of
the first things you'll do
is look down and ask
yourself, where'd my body go?
One thing we tried, which
really didn't work well,
is showing full body avatars.
Most VR systems today
track head and hands.
So by showing the
body, we're basically
predicting where the legs,
arms, and torso should be.
And most of the time,
we got this wrong.
People expected their
body to be in one place.
And when they looked, it
was in a different place
than they expected.
It feels really weird.
Full body avatars are
really hard to get right.
If you're going to use them,
be thoughtful about the design
and how they move.
Let's talk about designing
social interactions.
We've tested our
social experiments
with a lot of people.
Just like in real
reality, sometimes people
end up in the same room and
just had nothing to talk about.
So to remedy this,
think about giving users
a shared objective.
Giving them something
to play with together
makes it easy for them to
socialize and break the ice.
It was also interesting
for us to see
how free people felt in VR.
[LAUGHTER]
In case you don't
recognize him, that's
Manuel Clement, who
just spoke before me,
dancing like no one's ever
going to live stream this.
MANUEL CLEMENT: Robbie?
[LAUGHTER]
ROBBIE TILTON: Sorry
about that, Manuel.
[APPLAUSE]
Time after time, we saw
people willing to have
fun with others, dance
around, jump, and get goofy.
This is one of my favorite
parts about social in VR.
It's just a ton of fun.
When you put a few
people in a virtual room,
one of the first
things we saw is
that people try to physically
connect with each other.
For example, people
love high-fiving.
[LAUGHTER]
As a developer, explore ways to
amplify physical contact in VR.
As just one approach,
in this app,
we combined haptic feedback
with a fireworks animation
every time the hands connected.
Not everything in
VR is fun and games.
We noticed that some
simple interactions
that may seem innocent can
come across as trolling in VR.
Here you see a
shopping experience
where two people are trying on
different hats and accessories.
One user decides
to playfully put
a hat in front of the
other user's eyes.
[LAUGHTER]
While this may
seem harmless, this
can cause serious issues in VR.
This user couldn't see anything.
They felt like they
lost control and even
had to take their headset off.
Another common problem is people
getting too close to each other
and invading personal space.
So be cautious.
Test your apps out.
And make sure users
feel comfortable
in social experiences.
And with that, VR designers need
to start thinking about rules
and logic to prevent trolling.
In this example, you see
two dogs playing poker.
[LAUGHTER]
Player one is about
to lose a bet.
And you'll see that they get
up in frustration, intending
to take their chips back.
[LAUGHTER]
You'll also notice, when
they get out of their seat,
the world turns gray.
They disappear from the scene.
And they can no longer
interact with the world.
By design, players can
only see each other
when they're both seated.
This prevents
things like stealing
chips or even something worse
like physical confrontation.
This is just one approach.
We'd love to hear
more ideas from you
to encourage fair play.
Especially in these
early days, not everyone
will have access
to a VR headset.
But many people will want to
participate in the experience.
One thing we tried
is to let users film
and share from inside VR
with a virtual camera.
It's like filming
your own TV show.
You just grab the
camera and point it
at whatever you want
your audience to see.
This lets anybody watch
the VR participant
in the virtual world from any
screen like a phone or laptop.
For another example of this,
check out the spectator camera
in Tilt Brush.
We're super excited
about social in VR.
And we're even more
excited to hear your ideas
and what you guys
are going to build.
Now I'll pass it back to Mike.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE PODWAL: So
just to recap, we've
talked about interactions,
immersive worlds, and social.
And when you bring
these all together,
you can build some pretty
compelling experiences.
So to close this
talk, we're going
to walk through a few more
experiments that show how
we can combine these things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
People had so much fun
with the drums experiment
that we built another prototype
all about playing music
with friends.
You can play a virtual
xylophone, a harp, drum kit.
Of course, you can move these
around however you like.
And you can do
things that you can't
in real life with real drums
like stack five of them
on top of each other and strike
them all at the same time.
We call this one Architect.
Many architecture
firms use VR today
to preview a 3D model
that they've designed
on their desktop computer.
So we played with
the idea of letting
you design that model in VR.
You can grab materials and
pieces with direct manipulation
and get tactile feedback.
And when you place a
piece in a certain spot,
it just snaps right in,
interpreting your intention.
When you want to
preview your design,
you can step inside and get
a whole new perspective.
There are many examples of using
VR for storytelling, especially
in VR video.
This prototype lets anyone
be a storyteller in VR.
Here you can
animate virtual toys
into moving,
lifelike characters.
Inspired by motion capture
systems used in Hollywood
films, you grab
a couple of toys,
in this case Android
figurines, maybe a plane.
You move them through
space and time.
And then you replay the
scene and step into the world
that you've built.
It is make-believe
on a whole new level.
And that dog always
cracks me up.
We also love the notion
of a pure thrill.
And sometimes people
will get skeptical
of a VR experience that's
a little straightforward.
Where's the narrative?
Where's the utility?
We learned that sometimes
just being someplace amazing
is enough.
In this experiment, we attach
two controllers to your shoes
and asked you to go for
a walk off a diving board
53 meters in the air.
And it is absolutely terrifying.
And not everyone can do it.
But it's a lot of fun.
In this experiment, we
use social to teach you
a new language, in
this case, Mandarin.
You interact with a teacher who
gives you a new word to say.
You repeat it back.
And when you do a
good job, you get
verbal and non-verbal
feedback from the teacher.
You can also have
a nice interaction
with another student
in the classroom.
VR lets you see products
at their true scale.
This is especially
powerful for larger,
three-dimensional,
more expensive things
like furniture.
VR also lets you design
your store however you like.
So for this
experiment, we imagine
what it would be like to
shop for furniture in a 3D
model of a home.
You sample the
different products,
see how much they cost, maybe
check out a couple of chairs,
and then drop a specific
speaker in a specific spot
to see how it looks.
Or I guess you can make a tree
out of speakers-- #SpeakerTree.
And finally, we
built an experiment
for rehearsing performances
and presentations
with Google Slides.
[APPLAUSE]
And we may have
modeled this room
and maybe used it for
this specific talk.
So that's the last thing we
have to share with you today.
Before you go, we
have two quick things.
First, we have a lot of
great talks about VR today
and tomorrow.
We hope you check them out.
Later today, we have a talk on
monetization and distribution
for Daydream.
We have a talk on designing
for the Daydream controller,
where you can learn how to
make your own frying pan.
We also have a talk
on VR design process
where you can learn more about
how we do our rapid prototyping
at Daydream Labs.
This is just the start
of a conversation.
We're going to be posting
regular updates to our blog,
which is linked to here.
We really look forward
to staying in touch
and hearing your feedback.
Thank you so much.
We can't wait to see
what everyone builds.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]